me versus the peach okay I'm going to
swing the old meat mallet I'm gonna sit
on her right out of the box okay so I
could be calling for a little bit of the
old punch bagging okay buddy ready to
play the bag yeah yeah yeah give it to
me what what is it correct being in at a
TN you know it's kind of like the one
thing I didn't want to do
oh okay so what should I have left you
at parks the sink it's it's a TN man
it's the [ __ ] news it's Logan's
g-spot I can finger bang him all night
long I'm a direct direct to report what
sure just a TN it's it's like kind of
against my principles your principles
correct don't be an [ __ ] you don't
have principles dude etienne is a very
toxic element in the culture
seriously okay the name mean one
principle that you have I don't know
like I'm against racism [ __ ] I'm
against racism everybody's against
racism what else like don't lie [ __ ]
like if you're the news like you say
that's your principal yeah dude Greg
this is not [ __ ] Charles Dickens
world okay you don't go around talking
about principles we're all trying to do
the right thing of course we are but
come on man man the [ __ ] up
you